I want to read a quote from one of our
stories by Chris Palmieri and Lucas Shaw
saying that basically this is not
surprising the only thing not consistent
is that Sumner didn't fire Endowment
earlier
that's what monarchs do they kill people
in the pipeline who represent a threat
that's from Jeff salmon fells
a management professor at Yale could be
yeah but you know the people here
affiliate them all and George Abrams I
mean they're long-time trusted confidant
of Sumner Redstone have been you know
have helped him build this company from
scratch for decades so from that
perspective investors are stepping back
and saying that this is a shocking move
that occurred over the weekend and I
think investors are really really
questioning who made this move was it in
fact Sumner it would be very surprising
I think to some investors of that in
fact for the case or is it his daughter
Shari
influencing Sumner so those are the
questions I think the suits are going to
try this is shot in at the moment at
home correct the other question though
is that the man hasn't exactly you know
been wonderful for the stock price in
the last few years so I mean there would
have been a case to maybe get rid of him
anyway absolutely this is a media stock
that has underperformed it's big cap
appears the operations have
underperformed there's traditionally
been a very weak ratings across many of
their cable networks that have required
over the last year a lot of investment
to try to drive those ratings the
Paramount films Duty has fallen behind
some of its other peers in Hollywood so
if you take a look at the overall
fundamentals of the company there
clearly is an argument to be made and
investors certainly have made it by
pushing the stock down that this
management team has not performed well
certainly over the last two or three
years always a risk the judges story on
an intraday move but the stocks higher
exactly many cents in a session what's
that tell you I think it tells us that
investors are saying something is gonna
happen here we're going to get a
turnover in maybe management maybe board
structure certainly within turnover in
terms of the trust that manages this
company one of the outlooks or one of
the outcomes could possibly be you know
a sale of some are part of this company
to maximize shareholder value I think
that's a little presumptuous because I
think the real question that investors
have to answer is what is the trust
really looking to do are they looking to
maximize shareholder value or are they
looking to
perhaps just continue the legacy of
Sumner Redstone which will argue for
nothing happening yeah I mean National
Amusements owns 80% of the voting rights
of Viacom and of CBS and this is
apparently what Shari redstone wants to
get control of and this is what summoner
has been against what decides this or
who decides this is that the board of
director is right now is the courts it's
it's you know it altum Utley it's going
to be the trust that decides how the
shares of National Amusements
in Viacom and CBS are going to be voted
but it looks like right now the initial
part of contention will certainly be in
the courtroom as Philippe looks to
really challenge this ruling by Sumner
Redstone so that's going to be the
initial point of Shari have any support
among the directors she does she does
she has support and now with five
directors plus the two more that she's
gonna add that'll be seven she will have
presumably control over the trust now
which she does not which she did not
have under the prior structure